i found that less than 0.1 percent of
modern ladies have vision more or less
today leaders leading people into their
past or the best into their present
they are not leading people into the
future you know this famous discussion
or well-known discussion difference
between managers and leaders
managers are responsible for a present
leaders are responsible for a future
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact leap google
for startups and hippo and in media
partnership with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm with dr oleg konovalov
a thought leader author business
educator consultant and coach with over
25 years of experience operating
businesses and consulting with fortune
500 companies both in the uk and
internationally konovalov is on the
thinkers 50 radar has been recognized as
number one global thought leader on
culture by thinkers 360 and his number
one global leading coach by marshall
goldsmith thinkers 50.
having been named the da vinci of
visionary leadership by many leading
authorities of our time konovalov is
helping companies to create and execute
their vision diagnose and treat
organizational diseases maintain a
strong productive corporate culture and
achieve superior business performance
his research identifies entrepreneurs
and managers strategic needs in the
areas of corporate culture leadership
and uses corporate diagnostics in order
to enable them to drive their companies
to
succeed his doctoral degree from the
durham university business school he is
the visiting lecturer at a number of
business schools a forbes contributor
and an in-demand speaker at major
conferences around the world
[Music]
and really that's the whole point of the
show right talking about why we do what
we do what is the vision of what we do
now you're choosing to spend much of
your time today thinking about vision
thinking about leadership in business
you're in the united kingdom i i we
won't go into the details but you
happened to share with me a fun fact
before which i respect you tremendously
for and we'll keep that between us for
now or for a later episode but
but talking specifically about business
olegs tell me a little bit about
vision and why right now 2022 you are
deciding to focus most of your energy
thinking through what what vision means
for a business
i started thinking about vision and
important how to make it simple
actually long time ago it just
later i came up with my research in my
book
very practical research actually uh
the vision code
for me
oh if you would ask me what i do and
where my fashion is
my greatest passion to explore the
fields which never been explored before
we used to say before vision is
important okay we've been using vision
as some kind of a statement
and uh
co-founded motor
but vision is so practical it's so
pragmatic it's so functional that
must be not just
idolized it must be really practical
because in a good sense
companies
with strong vision and the ability to
execute it are
25 30 times more productive more
successful
than companies with just a great product
and actually
therefore i decided to look at something
which no one explored before in a great
sense and one of those fun facts i
have asked of one of my friends who is
responded in my book the vision code i
said
why people have not been looking into
this before is it
you need to have a still balls to look
at such tough subjects
you know
when we talk vision
we're talking to grow beyond ourselves
we're talking to do something beyond
that we could imagine
vision defines how we would live where
we would live and how our future would
look like
and therefore vision is not just some
kind of a statement which wouldn't
inspire anyone
vision is very pragmatic and it
defines your focus it defines how much
less resources do we need to achieve
more
it will define
the way you innovate
it will define evolution of your
business and evolution of industries or
domains in a great sense
well look at simple example
tesla
electrical cars were invented well
before elon musk but he defined that
space as his vision
and so we're looking differently now how
we drive how we serve cars
uh city infrastructures and many many
other things
it's redefinition how we would live
and therefore
it's always for instance for any startup
is critical it's not focused on the
product itself focus on the space that
you will take in the future and
therefore investors would be much more
keen to invest into such startup because
you already defining a market space
who's here space
and it will define how
so i want to ask a
clarification question
if we go back
you're right that vision has been around
for a while i mean vision statements any
entrepreneur today you'll ask them what
is your vision statement boom here's my
vision statement blah blah blah blah i'm
i'm and i'm so i'm i want to i want to
understand better it doesn't sound like
you mean a vision statement right
because there's a differentiation and
perhaps
the term vision
is a clear promise
where we are going to be in the future
and how this future will look like
it's not about mission statement
which is a promise that never delivered
we will be the greenest in the world
come on who cares we want to be number
one that's the ambitious it's nothing
about it
we will cr we will create the most
effective
solution for such a such problem that's
a vision
that is very different
another thing is
[Music]
you can leave your vision as a legacy to
the next generation of employees or
people who will buy out your company or
investors
by a mission statement
you can't actually transfer it it's
untransferable it's just promise for now
as your goal which is reasonable now we
know about for instance about nelson
mandela vision okay
so is still
intact
but we don't know about his mission
statement we don't know about his goals
because they were relevant to his times
and particular moments
in simple words if we think of a
analogy with a house
as a father as a husband i must build a
house that's purpose to be a father
but
how this
house would looks like who would live in
it
how what people would feel
living in that house would be my vision
my goals will be will be defining okay
how to
to lay the basement that rise the walls
and things like that how rooms to be
decorated those goals
that can be changed
and my mission statement would be that
house would be nice and we will be very
nice to neighbors
yay
you know so more or less is just a
promise just a social promise
that's a difference
right
now if we're looking at the landscape
today obviously
something bothered you about the way
that perhaps visions are being
laid out today or created
that perhaps aren't you know the best
way and and it it bothered you so much
that you decided to dedicate a lot of
your time thinking about this and
writing a book about it what is the
problem that we're facing today
around
entrepreneurs perhaps or business
leaders creating visions michael we
don't have
a problem we have a trouble
we have a huge trouble
i found that less than 0.1 percent of
modern leaders have vision more or less
today leaders leading people into their
past or the best into their present
they are not leading people into the
future you know this famous discussion
or well-known discussion difference
between managers and leaders
managers are responsible for a present
leaders are responsible for a future
and majority of leaders or company
owners are posit about the present
and they're stuck with their financial
reports
how they would look like to the public
today
but they're not changing the world
they're not making a huge difference
and therefore people are just looking at
them and thinking hey where do we go
what's the promise
how i would live better tomorrow or
within five years
and therefore the trouble is we're like
hamsters in a wheel we're repeating the
same old mistakes
we tend to talk about ai digitalization
and everything using the same old
mindset
and therefore it's not
about changing the thing in a big way
with all that technologies and
opportunities that we have it's about
breaking out of that old mindset which
would allow to create that vision
vision is not a gift vision is a way of
thinking it's a six-step algorithm
tell me a little bit about those steps
the first one i call that model caviar
forgive my
fishing industry experience but caviar
stands see
clarity of creation
your vision comes when your conscious
awareness of a problem that you want to
solve for a benefit of others reaches
its peak not just i have a fancy product
that people should like
no no no what problem do you want to
solve and the people will respond to it
it's about your ability because vision
is greater than you or any organization
you must be really good at managing and
winning it so you must grow if you want
to grow through collapse
it's about viability because it's very
practical it's very pragmatic and it
should be good in terms of stimulus
value
scale
how it we would add value value as we go
it's about simplicity because it's
elegant thinking about complicated
things
think
modern leaders
are brilliant
in one thing they're very specific
sophisticated in terms of making things
more complex vision is about making
things more simple elegant
and it's of course about yeah spotlight
or responsibility and about scanning
seeing what's going on around and about
passion
what do you put in emotional terms that
would allow you to go to the next point
influence because
influence is not just about
communicating your vision it's about
making others echo owners of your vision
and you will grow
right and of course no now why is that
important
let's dip for on this for a second
because you know a lot a lot of leaders
perhaps are you know aspiring to be the
the
the cornerstone of their vision to be
the the ones who know it the ones who
own it you're saying wait let's let's
share the vision aha there comes a very
difficult
issue
you people at your workshop
will hear about your vision
only when you get sick
talking about your vision at the board
level
because you must talk to everyone
otherwise people can't contribute to
your vision
they can't put their passion they can't
put your their ideas into your vision
therefore if you wouldn't share
and don't get me wrong people are lying
too much on the social media likes
but it's you know we're liking friends
without even reading that post
we're just supporting them so it's
meaningless but if people putting their
passion
it would allow spend less money on
marketing it's
less money on advertising people will
talk about your vision they will support
it and they will contribute it
and here comes the difference
we should communicate and share vision
we communicate facts and we share
emotions and we need to do both
to get people
and also important for people to see
that they will they will benefit from a
result of that vision
simple
and of course
well then that's a part of the vision
right exactly
and another thing is oh another
phase is acting of course because vision
is not about consensus it's not about
pleasing everyone it's about
being firm where they go
how good you are growing people how good
you're making or enabling people
in terms of decision making
uh put
metrics of your execution and so forth
and revitalizing because vision is not a
dead end it's always
must be revised
you grow you see more opportunities
you're expanding it you make an event
stronger
so simple caveat
well it sounds simple but it's not easy
to do now if
it it sounds simple but i'm sure that
each of these elements okay is unpacked
and i'm assuming that that's exactly
what you're doing in your book
now if we're looking at some of the
big game changers right i mean
a lot of these companies that are big
game changers now i'm trying i'm trying
to think back to the visions for example
we work
now it's really understandable why adam
neumann was able to have such a dramatic
influence for example one of the most
fundamental things we're talking about
is talking is is talking to your people
having them share your vision
showing them why your vision will make
them better right i mean that's a trait
of successful leadership exactly because
see
i mentioned that element stimulus
when people see the value for themselves
they will respond because stimulus
assumes response
immediate response if people don't see
that value
why they should respond to it they're
just like passing by
they work they say oh yeah that's a
solution because i can't afford to rent
an office i could rent
a chair
it doesn't matter you know a space
and we work and that was so often you
know one of the problems and it would
make my life easier and therefore just
like hey this guy created something that
made my life easier
so it would be better for you as well
immediately
how do you take something that's
boring
you know there's a lot of different
companies out there a lot of different
leaders and
and
does every ceo need to have a vision for
their product even if their product is
or even if their company
is something pretty narrow pretty niche
in other words is this method relevant
for every organization for every leader
that wants to build something meaningful
you know this famous
spray wd-40 we all have it you know
kitchens in our garages every formula
one team euros is more or less a single
product of wd-40 company and that
company 520 employees capitalization 3.5
billion dollars one of the strongest
brands in the world and the assault in
176 countries in the world and they are
still growing
single product
now
as
so what what does a ceo do so and and at
what point right so
my friends are creating startups at what
point gary rich
he still spends
most of his time on expanding vision
and talking to his people about it and
creating a strong culture based on that
vision
because ceo
paid
for defining and creating that future
civil is not paid
for managing today tasks
think of
jeff bezos
we all know that he's looking for
tapping on the things
like three years ahead from today
because that's his level three years
from now
lower
level executives are top income today
ceo is needed to lead define that future
and lead into that future
this is about leadership
so i thought i'm going to make it a
little bit more difficult at what point
does the ceo transition to be thinking
three years ahead because obviously if
you have a team of five people and
you've just started your business you've
just raised your seat round and you're
you know you're just getting started
i it doesn't make sense to me at that
point that the ceo sort of lives in the
in in the future world because they need
to be managing the fi the very finite
resources that they have today so how do
we know to make that distinction vision
is our aspiration that for the future
that we make a reality today
he might have a shorter
range horizon right instead of like five
or ten years he might say hey guys i
have a vision for three years but when
we're creating that vision today
and if
in this sense it's more important for
such a ceo or
owner
to make all others visionaries who would
help him to create to fix take care of
today
and help him to think about the future
because if you will stay grounded alone
anchored only to the two days you will
remain in that position forever
so there is would be no future hospital
interesting
so
you must access interesting
thinking you wouldn't be able to think
big you wouldn't be able to take
your company off the ground
you will still on a runway
and you will run out of fuel you will
run out of resources and you still would
be grounded
so it sounds to me like one of the
challenges that you're presenting for
ceos that perhaps they're not
necessarily a lot
are not exercising today it's
how do we how do they
create a situation
which allows them to spend much of their
time
creating that vision
and bringing that vision to their entire
team so that they are also a part of
that vision
and living that vision in the day-to-day
which which seems it seems high level
but it's not it's essentially meaning
how do i as a ceo make my organization
function as my vision for the future
and in such a way that allows me to
continuously fine-tune that vision and
bring it back to directory right because
if you don't do this let's put it in a
reverse logic if you would not do this
you don't know exactly what kind of
resources do you need so you are
choosing all sorts of resources most of
them are not needed
your energy is wasted your team
doesn't know where to where they these
people go more or less they're just
doing like
a single work every day without any
inspiration without any prospects for
tomorrow
for them this work is meaningless
actually
they're just like from eight to nine or
whatever just like nine to five whatever
the time
and actually
if you think from a point of view of
investors they're investing into your
promise of the future
they are not investing how good you are
at managing tasks today
[Music]
mm-hmm
sure
sure that that makes it makes perfect
sense and all i gotta do is
you're approaching
you beloved girl and you're saying hey
i want you to marry me because we're
good today or you're saying no
let's get married our future together
will be brilliant
i like that better
i promised my i like that better oh like
i think one of the apple juice
that i'm facing
is that
in one hand it seems very simple and
high level in the other hand it's like i
mentioned before it's not it's very
tangible you mentioned it's very
pragmatic it's very practical
in the day-to-day so i'm gonna take as a
homework to read the book because i
think that it's something that i'm going
to need as a leader myself and i and and
i appreciate this work i'm gonna i'm
gonna need some time to reflect back on
this conversation and constantly bring
it back down because i think people hear
vision
and they don't listen they they
they may
not feel that it's as
relevant or as current maybe it's
something that they do in their shower
or to their board meeting that they have
to prepare you know right before
and they don't give a necessarily the
same impact and the same intent
in the day-to-day
because what you're saying is that
vision isn't
in the board meeting it's not in your
fantasy powerpoint or on linkedin your
vision is the way that you live in your
company every moment every day it's the
it's what your
collaborators your employees envision
for themselves it's you're now creating
that vision of the future
and and what i hear you're also
mentioning is that a lot of times
leaders get stuck living in the present
and not necessarily in there or even in
the past or or in the past which is
obvious
and that's a bigger trouble which is
much worse oleg thank you very much this
was uh wonderful i appreciate your time
and your energy uh thank you for the the
great insights and and i can't wait to
take a look here michael
and see you soon
thank you
[Music]
you